[Music]
foreign
so the last few lectures I have shown
you how to solve systems of differential
equations with forcing so not just x dot
equals ax but we have this plus bu where
U is some control variable or some
forcing variable and today I'm going to
show you how to simulate these systems
in Python and in Matlab okay so there's
a ton of really really powerful tools
built in to both languages to work with
these kinds of control systems to do
things like compute the impulse response
and
simulate the linear system for an
arbitrary you do step responses things
like that
um
interestingly a lot of the technology
that is used in Matlab and python under
the hood goes way back like these
algorithms were written in Fortran I
think like the year I was born
essentially and they've been wrapped in
both languages uh so that you have all
of that massive control functionality
okay so
um a generic control
is not just going to have the dynamical
system or differential equation part
here
um
where uh here you'll also have an output
State Y which generally could be a
vector which is going to equal some
other Matrix c times x
plus another Matrix D times U and so I'm
going to decode this for you to start
with and then we're going to talk about
how to simulate these in Python and
Matlab so X is the internal state of
your system the internal
state
why is the measured or output State I
think of this as kind of the output of
the system but it's generally whatever
you can measure about the system and U
is the input typically the control input
that you want to manipulate so these are
input out output systems that have some
internal State X that might be higher
dimensional bigger than either you or Y
so maybe I have you know the global
Health population Dynamics and you know
there's billions of people on Earth they
all have some health state of whether
they're sick or healthy maybe they you
know we're trying to measure polio and
so I've got seven billion States in X
whether they have polio or not but I
can't measure all seven billion people
so my measurement is a massively smaller
measurement of this very high
dimensional internal State and you would
be my control intervention strategy okay
so that's just one example
for our purposes we want to plot the
full State X and so for our purposes we
are going to essentially assume
that Y equals X and so C is going to
equal the identity the N by n identity
and D is going to equal zero this
doesn't have to be the case but in the
python and Matlab examples I'm going to
choose C to be the identity because I
want to plot the full State X when I do
things like compute the impulse response
and the example I'm going to to code up
I wanted it to be a little physical so
I'm going to start with a you know a
pendulum where we have Theta
and we know that our Dynamics are Theta
double dot equals minus sine
theta plus some torque Tau where we're
applying torque Tau like that and before
I derived our linearized Dynamics in the
down position linearized about theta
equals zero we have these Dynamics DDT
of a state data
Omega
equals I'm pretty sure this is going to
go way over I hope that's not a problem
this is going to equal 0 1 minus 1 0.
of my state that's
Theta Omega
plus 0 1
Tau okay and so in this case we're going
to have our a matrix is equal to 0 1
minus one zero our B Matrix is going to
be 0 1 and as I mentioned before our C
Matrix is going to be the identity one
zero zero one so I measure both I plot
both Theta and Omega I measure both
Theta and Omega and my D Matrix is going
to be again 0 0. okay so this is the
system I'm going to simulate in Python
in Matlab and it corresponds to the
linearized down pendulum
good and I'm just going to show you all
of the cool commands like the impulse
response the frequency response the step
response the Nyquist and things like
that and I'm just going to kind of jump
in and start showing you this stuff now
I'll point out again I've said this many
times in the last few lectures I have a
whole boot camp on control theory where
we dive exclusively into these systems
so if you're interested in that you can
check it out
um
this isn't terrible I'm okay with this
and I'll point out that I also have this
book data driven science and engineering
where I have a couple of chapters
dedicated entirely to this control
system so if you really like this kind
of analysis uh chapters eight and nine
are all about that here and on our book
website
databook uw.com or on our GitHub
Dynamics lab
there will be all of these codes for all
of the control stuff in Matlab and in
Python
oops
I don't want to save this so I'm going
to discard it
um and maybe I'll actually start with
Matlab because there is a ton of python
control functionality built into python
but it is even more natively
um
built into Matlab so it's been built
into Matlab for the entire time I've
been using Matlab and so I think maybe
I'll just start there because it'll be a
little bit easier
and I'll make sure to give myself a
little room here
okay good so
by defining these system matrices a b
and c and then we are going to do things
like compute the impulse response and
the step response and you know the
frequency response things like that okay
so let's just do that
and I have it pretty much already built
in here so you know you can download
this code off of the course website
we're going to clear all close all CLC
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to enter this a matrix and I
can see that I've added a small teeny
tiny damping here I've added a little
friction a minus one
Omega term so I guess maybe I have a
minus 0.1
Omega term here in my Matlab Dynamics
that's fine that'll be interesting
that'll be
um
you know uh minus 0.1
Theta Dot
and this will be
minus 0.1 minus 0.1 this is going to
make it a little bit more stable
minus point
one minus 0.1 apparently I think that
was important good uh and then you know
my B Matrix similarly is 0 1 my C Matrix
is a two by two identity and my D Matrix
is zero that's what you expect and so in
Matlab it's really simple let's run this
it's really simple to initialize that
system so it is it's This Ss that that
stands for State space so this is a
state space system that's what this is
called
um this is a state
space
system
an SS system if you like the SS
um
not the Stasi the state space system is
this representation here it's
essentially a differential equation with
inputs and outputs and so just by
running SS of a comma B comma C comma D
I get a system and I think I just ran
that let's try this
okay and CIS is a continuous time State
space model with these parameters with
that a matrix B Matrix C Matrix and D
Matrix and so it makes it kind of nice
it actually tells you you know what are
the inputs and outputs U1 U2 X1 X2 y1 Y2
that kind of thing
and so once you have a state space
system in Matlab it's really easy to do
things like compute an Impulse response
or a step response or the arbitrary
input response so I'm just going to do
like impulse of my system this is like
one command
let's hope I ran that maybe I didn't yep
there it is and let me just make my uh
set
GCA
font size you know 24 something like
that to make it a little bigger
probably could do this and make all of
it a little bigger
um
I can make my line looks a little bit
bigger but you can see the kind of
output response of my system you know
it's this damped oscillator of the first
status Theta the second state is Omega
this is X1 and X2 and both of them are
kind of this out of phase damped
oscillation which is exactly what you
expect for a damped pendulum
um if I really wanted to I could
probably get the output of my impulse
response I would say you know impulse
uh system and it tells me what the
arguments are so uh the impulse of my
system and apparently T final is 100
here so this is going to do an Impulse
up until t 100. uh and I'm pretty sure
if I said
T comma x equals impulse that'll
actually spit out
a big Vector of time and then a
two-dimensional Vector
um X that is going to have both
components of
let's just say
what's the size of x
it only gave me one input and one output
oh it's X comma T sorry
and so what this is going to do is this
is going to spit out a vector
um
X which is size 2 by all of my time
instances or maybe time instances by
size 2 and a Time vector and I might do
this if I want to plot my own impulse
response because I hated the way that
plot looked it looked terrible so I'm
going to make a figure
and I'm going to have a subplot
you know two by two by one by one
and I'm gonna plot T by X of colon 1
line width
three
set GCA
[Music]
font size 24 and then subplot 2 by 1 by
2.
subplots and then similarly I'm going to
do the exact same thing but now I'm
going to plot the second state of x
hopefully this works and it just looks
way nicer okay so this is kind of how
you can pull that information out so
impulse is a really nice built-in
command if you just hit impulse it'll
plot it for you if you tell it hey I
don't want to plot it for me I want the
outputs of that impulse response you can
dump those into variables x and t and
you can plot them yourselves and it
looks a lot nicer
you
can do a step response I can do a step
of s of my system and instead of giving
it an impulsive input which is like a
Delta function input
so
impulse
is going to say U equals a Delta
function so U is literally some Delta
function at T
step
is going to say U equals 0
for time less than zero and one for time
greater than zero and so here U is
actually going to be a step up and so
you can do a step of your system and
give it a step response this is like if
you're in your car and you hit the gas
and you hold the gas so you want to you
know go faster you don't just impulse
the gas that's Feathering you want to
hold the gas that's a step input and
again it's a little hard to see here but
this is the step response of the system
you could dump those into a variable X
comma T and plot them if you like
uh and there's a ton of other cool
commands I could create some time Vector
from 0 to 50.
and I could create a u Vector let's just
do this right here
[Music]
um
I'll plot T comma U with a line width of
three and set my GCA font
size 24. and so I've just basically
created a u Vector that's the same
length as a Time Vector I started out
equaling to zero but then for the middle
third I'm going to have it look like
this big triangle I think let's see what
that looks like
yep so this is the control input U of T
a generic U of T that I want to input
into my system
and so it's easy if I don't want to just
do an Impulse or a step but I want to
see what is the response to an arbitrary
use some some U of T that I specify I
can do that here I can create this U of
T and then I can run this L Sim this
this simulates my linear system it's a
linear simulator of my system with this
generic control input U for that time
Vector t
and again if I run this it'll just
output X1 and X2 for those two states if
I wanted to I could dump those variables
into
X comma T equals and I could use my same
plotting routines from before and I'll
do that so it'll look a little nicer
and this is the
response of my system to that triangular
hat function input in U okay so that's
kind of cool you can do kind of impulse
responses step responses or you can
simulate the response to any old input
you you like whether it's a triangle
function or a sine function Anything You
Can Dream up it's really easy it's one
line L Sim
okay some other cool things you can do
is you can do something called a Bodhi
plot Bodhi of your system this is the
frequency response literally it is
um it'll give you the magnitude and the
phase of the response at as a function
of the input frequency so if U was a
sine wave of frequency Omega this will
tell you how big is the output given a
unit input at that frequency as a
function of frequency not just the
magnitude but also the phase of the
output very very useful built-in command
in Matlab okay so a lot of stuff you can
do with linear systems just completely
built in to to Matlab now I'm going to
show you python
uh good and there's actually a lot of
ways of doing this uh State space system
analysis in python as well
I would actually recommend probably the
um best place to start is using this
control uh toolbox box this python
control toolbox this is developed by a
large team of researchers
internationally I know Richard Murray at
Caltech has been involved when I was a
grad student
myself and a number of other grad
students actually wrapped a lot of these
old 1980s Fortran codes and put them
into python control so there's a lot of
the same functionality that you have in
Matlab in this python control toolbox
and if you report from control dot
Matlab everything it'll have exactly the
same
syntax as everything I just showed you
at Matlab so this is kind of nice you
can basically create transfer functions
you can create State Space Systems with
a b c d matrices you can do things like
compute the body plot that I just showed
you in Matlab here is the Bode plot in
in Python it looks nicer here because my
fonts are not tiny and illegible
let's see what else you can do yeah you
can create a b c d matrices and create
you know systems State Space Systems or
transfer function systems you can
compute the impulse response really
easily in the same way one line to get
the impulse response and so on and so
forth so tons and tons of functionality
in this python control toolbox
all of this again
I have this in chapter eight of my book
that I showed you so all of those codes
are on databook uw.com
or on our Dynamics lab GitHub page and
it all uses this built-in control
toolbox if you don't want to import that
because it requires you know maybe
there's some overhead to importing that
you can also use this kind of built-in
scipy signal toolbox that has a lot of
these these functionalities too for
example that has a built-in State space
impulse and L Sim
so this is the code that um Alan
captanaglu modified from mine so
similarly if we run this it'll import
all of these it'll create these a
matrices again with a small damping
and then creating it's again the exact
same kind of notation State space to
create the state space system
and then to create an impulse and plot
it is you know just as easy as before
one line impulse and then similarly you
know creating this U function that we're
going to input for a generic U
and L Sim is again a one-line built-in
command using this scipy
functionality so pretty nice you can
simulate you can build and simulate
these State Space Systems you can
compute their impulse responses their
step responses their arbitrary system
responses their frequency responses you
can do that all in python or in Matlab
really really powerful stuff you can
design controllers remember when I
showed you how to stabilize that
inverted pendulum we designed a u equals
KX
um that stabilized that inverted
pendulum all of that code to design
stabilizing controllers and common
filters and anything you can dream up in
control theory is pretty much now built
into both Python and Matlab and if
you're interested you know I have a ton
more stuff in my control boot camp and
on the book where you can check that out
this is really supposed to just be a
teaser showing you you know for these
systems there's a lot of software out
there okay that's it for now thank you
[Music]